with the first steamships came the
tourists that was at the beginning of
the 19th century the middle rhine valley
was one of the earliest examples of mass
tourism in Europe the drossel gasa
andrew de time is a must on any rhine
tour to this day whole fleets of
excursion boats are at the ready we
board in rue de time and travel as far
as st. goar
we pass many medieval castles there are
supposed to be 40 of them they in the
landscape are the main attraction of the
middle rhine valley
picturebook towns line the shore at
their feet is the Rhine at their back
the vineyards we set course for the city
of Barack
in the Middle Ages bacharach was the
main wine trading center in the middle
rhine valley and thus a rich city the
houses in the center of town are more
than 500 years old making Bacharach a
lovely goal for an outing in those days
traders along the river had to pay toll
to the owners of the Rhine castles who
grew rich on the fees
schoenberg castle an oboe vasil the lord
or lease holder of a castle still has to
know how to earn a living today hammond
hurdle is a third-generation hotel yay
nineteen hundreds even finish in 1957 my
grandparents least the castle from the
city for 90 years they started with a
little newsstand over the years they
turned that into a beautiful hotel and
restaurant in the castle walls my
parents took it over in 1982 back then
it had 14 rooms and I expanded it today
it has 22 rooms Sinmun like Sundberg
many other castles are today hotels
romanticism is good business medieval
atmosphere with modern conveniences and
a view of the rhine we are approaching
the narrowest part of the river the
famous Lorelei rock at st. Gore's
housing for texts and hidden shelves
once caused many shipwrecks here the
Lorelei rock towers 132 meters above the
river today tourists enjoy the view of
the tamed river in the 19th century
artists were fascinated by the ryans
landscapes they earned fame as the Ryan
romantics and made the middle rhine
valley famous too
in st. goar we meet the Pater armand
thomas and ask him what made the Rhine
so attractive for the romantics because
I in a romantic but see the term Ryan
romanticist I first were certain way of
approaching this thing tema romantic
romanticism means the human yearning for
a connection between nature and culture
Kootra went along the Rhine especially
in the middle rhine valley this
connection between nature and medieval
culture was present in an ideal fashion
in 2002 the middle rhine valley was
declared a unesco world heritage site
like the castles the vineyards are an
integral part of the landscape a closer
look reveals shrubs taking over and many
vineyards
the young vintners thomas and martin
phillips want to do something about that
for years they have been reclaiming
steep slopes near st. goar that lay
fallow than the human launched off if
you live in a landscape like this and
have always worked in the vineyards then
you want them to be preserved we
vintners are a kind of landscape
preservationist and the whole situation
motivated us on the scans aha Johnson
automotive yards in Xanth goa we have
these fantastic terroirs or locations
with strong highly mineralized Riesling
grapes this made us want to recall
tivated surfaces to replant them
annoyance of langson the wine growing
estate has its own tavern a tradition in
this region it provides good food and
drink and conviviality far from the
maddening crowd our ship turns around
now the order is full steam ahead back
to root is high him against the current
and the landscape passes by once again
from the other direction
you